so
you know crispr right crispr is
this genome guidance and cutting
mechanism
it's what george like likes to call
genome vandalism
so you basically are able to
you can basically take a guide rna
that you put into the crispr system and
the crispr system will basically use
this guide rna scan the genome
find wherever there's a match and then
cut the genome
so you know i digress but it's a
bacterial
immune defense system so basically
bacteria are constantly attacked by
viruses
but sometimes they win against the
and they chop up these viruses and
remember as a trophy
inside their genome they have this loci
this crispr loci
that basically stands for clustered
repeats interspersed
et cetera so basically it's it's an
interspersed repeats uh
structure where basically you have a set
of repetitive regions
and then interspersed were these
variable segments
that were basically matching viruses so
when this was first discovered
it was basically hypothesized that this
is probably a bacterial immune system
that remembers
the trophies of the viruses that manage
to kill
and then the bacteria pass on you know
they sort of do lateral transfer of dna
and they pass on these memories so that
the next bacterium says oh you killed
that guy
when that guy shows up again i will
recognize him and the crispr system was
basically evolved as a bacterial
adaptive immune response
to sense foreigners that should not
belong
and to just go and cut their genome so
it's an rna guided
rna cutting enzyme or an rna guided dna
cutting
enzyme so there's different systems some
of them called dna some of them called
rna
but all of them remember this
sort of viral attack
so what we have done now as a field is
you know through the work of
you know jennifer donna emmanuel
carpentier
and many others is co-opted that
system of bacterial immune defense as a
way to cut
genomes you basically have this
guiding system that allows you to use an
rna guide
to bring enzymes to cut dna at a
particular locus
that's so fascinating just so this is
like already a natural mechanism
a natural tool for cutting that was
useful
this particular context yeah and we're
like well we can use that thing to
actually
it's a nice tool that's already in the
body yeah yeah it's not in our body it's
a bacterial body
it was discovered by the by the yogurt
industry
they were trying to make better yogurts
and they were trying to make their
bacteria
in their yogurt cultures more resilient
to viruses
and they were studying bacteria and they
found that wow this crispr system is
awesome
it allows you to defend against that and
then it was co-opted in mammalian
systems that don't use anything like
that
as a as a as a targeting way to
basically bring these dna cutting
enzymes
to any locus in the genome why would you
want to cut dna
to do anything the reason is that our
dna has a dna repair mechanism
where if a region of the genome gets
randomly cut you will basically scan the
genome for anything that matches
and sort of use it by homology
so the reason why we're deployed is
because we now have a spare copy
as soon as my mom's copy is deactivated
i can use my dad's copy
and somewhere else if my dad's copy is
deactivated i can use my mom's copy
to repair it so this is called
homologous
based repair so all you have to do is
the the cutting and that's it you don't
have to do the fixing that's exactly
right you don't have to do the fixing
because it's already built in that's
exactly right but the fixing
can be co-opted by throwing in a bunch
of homologous
segments that instead of having your
dad's version
have whatever other version you'd like
to use
so the thing so you you then control the
fixing by throwing in a bunch of other
stuff that's exactly right
that's how you do genome editing so
that's what crispr is that's what's
wonderful
in popular culture people use the term
i've never well that's brilliant that's
so it's a crisp recent explanation
genome vandalism followed by a bunch of
band-aids
that have the sequence that you'd like
and you can control the the choices of
band-aids correct yeah and of course
there's new generations of
crispr there's something that's called
prime editing that was
sort of very very much in the press
recently that basically instead of sort
of making a double stranded break
which again is genome vandalism you
basically make a
single stranded break you basically just
nick one of the two strands enabling you
to sort of peel off without sort of
completely breaking it up
and then repair it locally using a guide
that is coupled to your initial rna
that took you to that location dumb
question but
is crispr as awesome and cool as it
sounds
i mean technically speaking in terms of
like
as a tool for manipulating our genetics
in the positive meaning of the word
manipulating
or is there downsides drawbacks in this
whole context of therapeutics that we're
talking about yeah or understanding and
so
so so um when i teach my students about
crispr
i show them articles with the headline
genome editing tool revolutionizes
biology
and then i show them the date of this
tool of these articles and they're 2004
like five years before crispr was
invented and the reason
is that they're not talking about crispr
they're talking about zinc finger
enzymes
that are another way to bring these
cutters to the genome
it's a very difficult way of sort of
designing the right set of zinc finger
proteins the right set of
amino acids that will now target a
particular long stretch of dna
because you you know for every location
that you want to target you need to
design
a particular regulator a particular
protein
that will match that region well there's
another technology called talens
uh which are basically you know just a
different way of using
proteins to sort of you know guide these
cutters to a particular location of the
genome
these require a massive team of
engineers of biological engineers to
basically design
a set of amino acids that will target a
particular sequence of your genome
the reason why crispr is amazingly
awesomely revolutionary
is because instead of having this team
of engineers
design a new set of proteins for every
locker that you want to target
you just type it in your computer and
you just synthesize an rna guide
the beauty of crispr is not the cutting
it's not the fixing
all of that was there before it's the
guiding
and the only thing that changes that it
makes the guiding easier
by sort of you know just typing in the
rna sequence
which then allows the system to sort of
scan the dna to find that
so the coding the the engineering of the
cutter is
easier on the uh in terms of
that's kind of similar to the story of
deep learning versus uh
old school machine learning some of the
some of the challenging parts are
automated
okay so uh but crispr is just one
cutting technology exactly and then
there's that's part of the challenges
and exciting opportunities of the field
is to design
different cutting technologies
you